foreign
[Music]
up in leicestershire in the 1950s there
isn't much to keep a young mind occupied
children spend a long summer afternoons
unsupervised roaming over every inch of
the towns Villages and surrounding
Countryside
purely for something to do
so when school girl Tina negus comes to
her teachers with Tales of strange
markings on the Rocks near her favorite
Blackberry picking sport in charnwood
forest
[Music]
they shrug it off as little more than
the imaginings of a board adolescent
[Music]
a year later three more school children
Richard Allen Richard blachford and
Roger Mason are scrambling over the same
rocks when they too spot something
curious inscribed in the Stone
[Music]
despite the conviction of all three
their jaded teachers refused to believe
them thinking it merely to be a ruse
designed to lure them out into the woods
and forego their lessons for a fun day
out in the forest
foreign
no more thought
but Roger Mason is not so easily
deterred
with the support of his father who never
doubts anything young Roger says he goes
straight to the most senior geologist he
could find
[Music]
despite his commitments as professor of
geology at Leicester University
Trevor Ford is won over by Rogers Ernest
plea and concedes to scramble among the
blackberries and over the sloping rocks
to see what the boy has found
and as it turns out none of the school
children had been lying
pushing aside brambles in the leaf
litter Trevor runs his fingers over some
of the most remarkable and puzzling
structures he has ever seen
they look like leaves or gigantic
feathers trodden into the Rock by some
Titanic Force
each of their delicate veins is picked
out in Exquisite detail by the subtle
rise and fall of the Sandstone itself
at the time Ford knew of no mechanism by
which a leaf or feather could become so
impressed in solid sandstone
except at the moment of that Rock's
formation
leading him to the inescapable
conclusion that this was a fossil
remnant of some unknown organism or
process
[Music]
and yet even more remarkably Ford knows
that this area of charnwood forest is
underlained by some of the most ancient
rocks in England
[Music]
they are pre-cambrian long predating the
appearance of leaf-bearing plants or
feather-clad Birds
[Music]
in fact these rocks long predate any
known fossil visible with the naked eye
[Music]
this specimen staring defiantly back
from the surface of the rock is a
paradox a conundrum
in that moment young Roger and the
professor find themselves teetering on
the edge of a precipice of Discovery
much greater than the small Bluff that
they are standing on
this find is something Stranger Than
Anything the geological world has seen
for a hundred years
in time Trevor Ford would extract the
precious fossil from its brackney home
huge slabs of rock weighing more than
200 kilograms are levered out and
transported back to the university
the strange structure is confirmed as a
fossil of a long-lost creature of
immense Precambrian age
but this chania masoni so named for its
modern day home forest and the tenacious
child that found it is but the first of
many such fossils to be ultimately
recovered from rocks of that age
and together they paint a picture of a
stranger world than any paleontologist
would dare to imagine
in the Twilight of the protozoic not
long before the dawn of animals as we
know them the sea floor bristles with
truly alien life
where before there had been little more
than a few branching algae and fungal
filaments
for the very first time there are now
living behemoths cast their Shadows
across the shallows
looming eerily across the Abyssal Plains
strange quilted pennants wave in the
current
bushy thickets of fleshy plumes tangle
amongst themselves
and vast flattened sheets flap and
Tumble across the ocean bottom
this is a biological World unlike
anything seen before or since but the
pre-cambrian Rocks do not lie
for a brief period these alien life
forms really did rule our seas
what were they where did they come from
and what became of these first strange
experiments of evolution as the sun rose
on the Cambrian world
we still have tens of millions of years
to go
but we're now very close to the Cambrian
explosion
perhaps the single most important event
in the history of life on earth when
Life as We Know It exploded into being
in the primordial Seas
with that in mind our recommendation on
curiosity stream this month is ancient
oceans
[Music]
a fascinating look at the order vision
and devonian periods when colossal
monsters stalked their prey beneath the
waves and our ancestors made their first
tentative steps onto the land
this is just one series amongst
thousands you can access right now on
curiosity stream
from the depths of space to the
dinosaurs there is a vast range of
programs to choose from
added less than 20 a year it's an
excellent deal so go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
history of the earth to sign up and
using the code history of the earth will
save you an additional 25 percent
that's just over a dollar a month
thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting education on YouTube
[Music]
an entire decade before Roger Mason and
his classmates fought to get their
mysterious fossils the attention they
deserved
a very similar event unfolded Halfway
Around the World
and this time with adults geologists who
really ought to have known better
[Music]
in 1946 the Australian geologist
Reginald Sprigg found himself in the
barren Wilds of the Flinders range in
South Australia
he'd been sent by his government to
determine whether defunct silver and
copper mines in the area could be made
profitable once again
he worked alone after all it didn't take
a big team to peer into the dark
recesses of an over-exploited mine and
see that it was Bare
[Music]
and so as he sat eating his lunch in the
shade of a stunted sugar gum
listening to the lazy droll of insects
in the afternoon heat he absent-mindedly
turned over the plate-like slabs of rock
around him
the layers had been baked free from
their parent Bedrock by the sheer heat
of the Sun
and now Ridge peered with Fascination at
the strange markings to be seen on their
newly aired undersides
up to 10 centimeters across they were
broadly circular
concentric in places sometimes endowed
with radial ridges around their outer
edges
to Reg they look just like the jellyfish
he'd often seen stranded on the beaches
of his South Australian hometown
to him they were far too complex to have
been made by inorganic geological
processes
he was convinced that they were fossils
and named the group of strange circular
forms after the Aboriginal name for the
Sheep station closest to his lunch spot
ediacra
and yet reg sprig faced a conundrum
he knew enough about the local geology
and the nature of the fossil record in
these parts to be thoroughly confused
the rocks of the Flinders ranges were
supposed to be pre-cambrian in age
but fossils of this size and complexity
were known only from rocks that were
Cambrian and younger
that's just how it was
[Music]
the beginning of the Cambrian was marked
by the appearance of fossils
and if these idiacron structures were
indeed fossils then the rocks that he
sat amongst must in fact be Cambrian
so Shaw was Rage of their biological
nature that he was willing to rewrite
the stratigraphic history of the area to
allow them to exist
but not everyone was so convinced of reg
Spriggs seemingly Cambrian jellyfish
reg wrote a paper detailing his findings
and submitted it to the prestigious
journal Nature surely a discovery like
this warranted the attention of all
natural scientists worldwide he thought
but the paper
was rejected
and when he returned to the premier of
Australia with news of his remarkable
discovery
the minister reportedly waved him away
saying give me good copper lead ore any
day
even when discussing them among his
colleagues and fellow geologists the
structures were dismissed as fortuitous
inorganic markings
in their kindest possible words his
contemporaries made it clear to Reg that
they thought he was seeing things
perhaps the Australian heat had finally
gone to his head
[Music]
ultimately although reg endured the
humiliation as long as he could bear he
gave up on his Cambrian jellyfish and
instead went looking for oil with much
greater success
and yet remarkably though even this
wasn't the first time that these strange
late Precambrian markings had been found
and subsequently ignored
before the feather-like chania was
uncovered by innocent school children in
the 1950s
English examples of the same curious
ring-like structures as in Australia had
actually been identified as far back as
the mid-1800s
but once again they were dismissed as
inorganic markings
formed in the Rock itself hardened and
compressed with no biological
contribution necessary
foreign
book on the geology of the area
published 100 years later they didn't
even warrant a mention
[Music]
but all this changed with chania masoni
[Music]
much more elaborate much more compelling
than the simple concentric ring
there was no doubt about the structure's
origin
it was a fossil for sure and Trevor Ford
even had the conviction to stick firmly
to its pre-cambrian age
[Music]
there was no more dismissing the
ediacran structures as anything less
than what they truly were
remarkable evidence of a new kind of
macroscopic protozoic life
interest was renewed in the Australian
specimens too and more and more diverse
forms were found adding to the picture
of this so-called idiacran biota
[Music]
interest in these enigmatic life forms
only grew over the following decades
more and more fossil Impressions were
found dating to this final stage of the
proterozoic
[Music]
in England Australia Namibia the White
Sea of Russia Siberia China Brazil
Canada and Ukraine
[Music]
soon the ediacran biota was a global
phenomenon
and paleontologists worldwide race to
find and identify new members of this
most curious of fossil assemblages
such was the Cascade of new science
coming from this paleontological Gold
Rush that an entirely new geological
division was proposed
to demarcate those rocks lucky enough to
have formed at the time in which the
fossils are found
and so in 2004 the ediacaran period was
finally ratified
it is the newest of geological
subdivisions and the first to have been
made for 120 years
extending from its lower bound to 635
million years ago which is marked by the
global cap carbonates that followed the
last snowball glaciation
all the way up to the beginning of the
Cambrian Period and
538.8 million years ago
the ediacron period marks just less than
100 million years when for the first
time in Earth's history
giant organisms ruled the Seas
[Music]
in southern Newfoundland the late summer
brings violent storms the Lash the
coastline with howling winds and
horizontal rain
stunted Juniper and cloudberry bushes
grow sideways pressed flat against the
ground in the hopes of avoiding the
worst of the damaging gusts
the cliff tops are soaked by towering
waves that exhaust their energies
against the solid Stone
and the sea spray obscures the Ragged
Cliff edge with a cold stinging mist
even on the rare calm days the coastline
is obscured by this Mist whose whose
tendrils reach up over the craggy rocks
[Music]
Sailors battling the storms as they
charred the northeastern coast of Canada
see the cliffs looming out of the Mist
and spray and turn north believing that
they've passed Cape race and have a
clear path into the northern Atlantic
but they are deceived there are two such
Bluffs
and turning too soon sees the luckless
Mariners driven hopelessly onto the
rocks of Southern Newfoundland
this so-called mistake on point has
misled Sathers time and time again and
now in the bait of the East nearly 100
wrecks lie
foreign
but not every day at mistaken point is
beset by storms and fog and not every
ship falls fouled of its treachery
on occasion the sun shines a golden
light onto the southern peninsula
Illuminating the sloping rocks that jut
out to sea
without the crashing waves to obscure
them the Crags are revealed as smooth
stepped surfaces each a petrified memory
of a sea floor long past
[Music]
and on those ancient sea floors a
shallow etchings and Scrolls only
revealed in their True Glory by the low
angled rays of a late afternoon sun
crawling along the gently slanted planes
with nose scarcely six inches above the
rock's surface
a paleontologist can imagine herself
snorkeling through the ediacaran ocean
during its prime
such is the Bounty of the fossils to be
found on this remote Windswept Shoreline
foreign
organisms here in Newfoundland are
typical for the period
they look as if they have been pressed
into soft mud which is since hardened to
freeze their Impressions through 600
million years of geological time
and this is indeed how they are formed
there are no shells or bones no hard
Parts at all to be found within them
the life forms that left these Death
Masks did so with only soft fleshy
bodies that have long since decayed away
that these imprints have lasted as long
as they have is impressive in itself but
the detail they preserve is enough to
take one's breath away
laid before the incredulous
paleontologist is a veritable Garden of
ediacara
there are specimens of chania very
similar to the feather-like form found
in England
these gently curving forms can be less
than one centimeter long of their
smallest
and reach more than 60 centimeters at
their largest
looking like a finely quilted air bed
that narrows towards its tip
in life they stood alone
and direct from the muddy surface
pointing their tips up into the water
in death they are felt unceremoniously
into the mud
other organisms seem to prefer a more
lowly existence
[Music]
fractal fuses or the spindle creature is
found face down in the silt in death as
it would have been in life
it is made of many repeating chanya-like
elements broadly mirrored along a
central axis with each becoming thinner
towards its two pointed tips
scattered along the sea floor they look
like the detritus of An Early Autumn
Leaf fall
Brad gaitier is constructed from many
fractal fuses and charnia-like elements
bundled together in three-dimensional
shrubs like so many informal cabbages
each prefers its own personal space as
they're seen evenly distributed across
the ediacaran sea floor protruding
bulbously some 20 centimeters above the
surface
everything
Ives headier is the only fossil among
the ancient god in a mistaken point that
raises questions in its interpretation
early researchers who documented the
fossils referred to them as Pizza discs
due to their resemblance to a lumpy
circle of indistinct shapes
seemingly United by a formless smear of
molten cheese
[Music]
there was no symmetry or definite
structure to unite them
[Music]
Scholars suggested them to be the
remains of balloon-like structures that
were once Tethered to the sea floor but
have since descended and deflated
others suppose they were formless by
Design much like modern day sponges
but the discovery of some fractal
fuses-like elements embedded like
Wayward pepperoni in these ancient Pizza
discs suggests that they were in fact
colonies of the familiar forms that have
decayed where they sat before being
frozen in time
[Music]
and so the garden of ediacara in
Newfoundland
is Rich and diverse considering the
paucity of macroscopic life to be found
from the preceding billions of years
but there is yet more idiacran bounty to
be recovered from other parts of the
late protozoic ocean now found scattered
around the globe
in Australia where Reginald Sprigg first
found his jellyfish-like forms
the soft-bodied fossils are also
preserved as imprints in the ancient
Rock surfaces
but unlike mistaken point where a
paleontologists need only Brave the
occasional breaking wave as they walk
across the former sea floor out in the
finder's range the searching is much
more back-breaking work instead of being
squashed down into the mud of the floor
Australian idiacarans are instead
impressed on the underside of bedding
Planes cast by the overlying sediment
before the fleshy organisms have a
chance to decay
and so the hopeful paleontologist must
search among these Rocky seethings
either by turning over heavy Rock slabs
or by crawling wholesale under
overhanging Cliff edges
but the fossils found there are well
worth the strenuous effort
insomnia appears as a Giant's thumbprint
in the sand
ridges radiate out from a central axis
curving gently to the shallow tip that
marks it Outer Perimeter which is
roughly circular or oval in shape
size variation of these imprints is
staggering too
specimens range from just a few
millimeters to well over a meter across
but never grow more than a centimeter in
thickness
[Music]
in distinct sequential impressions in
the sand suggest the life form either
hopped along the surface
or was blown tip over tail like
discarded newspaper in the Wind
kimberella is little more than a ridged
oval-shaped flange surrounding a
misshapen lump sometimes with a
tube-like protrusion extending from one
of its narrowed ends
and yet it's often found alongside
scrape-like markings in the soft
sediment surface
it could be coincidence or it could be
evidence of a slug-like organism
searching blindly for food
and there are many more strange forms
besides in total more than 200 different
species have been described from
ediacaran rocks some like chania
fractophusus and bragatia show clear
relations to one another
but others are no more Associated than
mindless Doodles in the sand
[Music]
[Applause]
staggering array of shapes sizes and
Lifestyles to be found in the ediacron
oceans united only by their lack of
mineral support and of course their
complete absence in our ecosystems today
and so what are the alien organisms that
ruled our late proterozoic oceans
and how can they really be so different
to all subsequent life on Earth
[Music]
Martin Glassner is a dedicated man
[Music]
his mind is never quiet ever worrying
ever pondering the mysteries of the
natural world
even when the austro-hungarian is
confined to a military Hospital in
Moscow in the 1930s suffering from
scarlet fever he cannot bring himself to
waste the hours laid up in bed
[Music]
instead he ruminates on the contents of
a new book
focused on the microscopic world of tiny
fossils that helped to guide oil
Prospectors in their search for black
gold
desperate not to lose the inspiration
born of his enforced bed rest he
scribbles notes on borrowed Hospital
paper
and those notes need to be boiled to
kill the fever-causing germs before they
can be sent home to his wife for typing
[Music]
keeping his mind busy clearly helped his
body recover
soon enough he returned to oil
prospecting work
during the later years of the second
world war he moved Halfway Around the
World to Australia
just before questions about his Jewish
Heritage could disturb his work
he finished his book
and continued to search for life in the
Australian Wilderness before turning his
attention in the late 1950s to rocks far
too old to contain oil
in a way he acted out the reverse of
Reginald Spriggs ediacaran Journey
since the luckless red should turn to
petroleum after no one seemed to care
about his ancient Sandstone fossils
but for glesner the intervening 10 years
made all the difference
in that time the English fossils of
chania had been discovered and the truth
of the ediacaran biota was beginning to
emerge
[Music]
this was a brand new area of
paleontological study
and Martin glesner was eager to give it
his full attention
studied every example of the idiacarans
he could get his hands on documenting
their peculiar morphology and singular
mode of life
by now their true pre-cambrian age was
clear
and glessner pondered the relationships
between these strange forms and the more
familiar animal fossils that were to be
found in rocks just a few millions of
years younger
he came to a logical conclusion based on
what he knew about the nature of
evolution and the fossil record from
younger times
these bizarre organisms preserved as
death masks in the sand must be
precursors to Modern animals
the so-called missing link that helps to
fill the gaps between a predominantly
microscopic protozoic and the dawn of
animal Life as We Know It
[Music]
it was a reasonable assumption
considering the unprecedented suddenness
of the Cambrian explosion
and so with this in mind glesner set
about trying to find the ancestral forms
of each of the main animal groups among
the fossils of the ediacaran
the famed chania quite closely resembles
a kind of soft Coral called a sea pen
named for their resemblance to feather
quills used for writing
these corals belong to one of the most
simple and primitive of animal groups
the cnidarians along with hard corals
that build mineral skeletons and a
variety of free swimming jellyfish
foreign
s are united by their stinging cells
that help them to stun and catch their
planktonic prey
and today sea pens can be found rooted
into soft sand worldwide
extending their feather-like veins
upwards to sweep the water clear of food
the concentric rings that first peaked
Reginald sprig's interest are now
classified as fossils named aspadella
which includes various rounded forms
that range in size from one millimeter
to almost 20 centimeters in diameter
klezner thought they were the perfect
candidate for the other abundant kind of
cnidarian the jellyfish
certainly the larger forms could easily
be mistaken for the jellies stranded on
the beach
another idiacaran organism named
sprigina after reg sprig himself appears
to be symmetrical around a central axis
with ridged body and a bulbous head at
one end
Martin interpreted it as one of the
first steps towards worms
which are some of the most dominant
forms of the Cambrian explosion
and there were many more animal
ancestors to be found
Martin glesner and his colleague Mary
Wade spent 25 years neatly pigeonholding
the ediacaran organisms into modern
taxonomic categories they even
identified basil members of some of the
higher animal groups
like echinoderms which include the
starfish and sand dollars and which are
the closest invertebrate relatives to
the chore dates otherwise known as the
vertebrates which includes humans
[Music]
the diacran fossils tribatrium and
akarua have five part and three-part
symmetry respectively something that's
shared by many modern echinoderms but if
extremely rare amongst any larger
animals
with their diligent work glesner and
Wade's animal interpretations became
almost synonymous with the ediacran
biota itself
when museums sought to refresh their
displays with the compelling fossil
Impressions and their living Missing
Link interpretations the dioramas would
inevitably feature sea pen like chania
waving from the surface
blinds Regina worms inching along the
mud and primitive jellyfish swarming the
sunlit waters
but there is a problem
despite their Valiant efforts to match
one to another these Scholars work is
little more than simply that
matching
and when these patterns are subject to
scrutiny the kind of scrutiny that's to
be expected when searching for the
ancestors to all animal life the navel
of similarity begins to drop away
revealing fatal flaws in this simplistic
interpretation
's resemblance to Sea pens for example
the modern forms although they differ in
size and color all have a common mode of
living and mode of growth
feather-like cnidarians tend to retreat
into their muddy Burrows when danger
Looms but there is no trace of burrows
beneath any example of chania yet
discovered
not only that but the sea pens grow from
the bottom as seen by the smaller
segments that are to be found at the
base of the feather-like vein
[Music]
in contrast China's smallest elements
are invariably found at the top
[Music]
on closer inspection the case for their
similarity falls apart of the seams
[Music]
the circular Impressions left by
aspedala are indeed reminiscent of
beached jellyfish but they lack many of
the other diagnostic features of jellies
there are no trading tentacles no
prominent gonads
nothing in fact beyond the slumped and
wrinkled circular impression
they are no more similar to jellyfish
than they are to an abandoned omelet
plus many examples of the same structure
have been attached to the basis of
china-like fossils which makes any free
floating interpretation challenging at
best
[Music]
and the compelling symmetry of tribech
idiom and akarua that places them
optimistically among the echinoderms
begins to wear thin when that same
symmetry is to be found elsewhere
throughout the living kingdoms
from Tiny single-celled organisms to the
broccoli in your fridge and the roses in
your garden one of a self-similar
elements need to be packed gradually
it's most efficient for them to do it
with three and five-fold symmetry
what's more many other ediacaran
organisms like teradynium and swapuntia
which glissner very slow scribe to
cnidarians and other animal groups
also possess the three and five-fold
symmetry so this feature alone cannot be
diagnostic of a higher invertebrate
group
even the bilateral symmetry along a
central axis seen in fossils like
dickinsonia and spragina which tempt us
to draw parallels with the evolutionary
branches that eventually led to us is
not quite as it seems instead of being
truly mirrored along a central seam the
riches and repeating quills of many the
acarins are actually slightly offset
this gives the central line a zigzag
appearance and is a kind of symmetry
known as a Glide plane which isn't seen
in any modern animal group at all
on balance the ediacron organisms May
superficially possess certain
characteristics in common with animal
groups but they unanimously fail to
present any of the features that would
be considered diagnostic for any animal
they have no evidence of a mouth gut or
anus no organs that could definitively
be said to be used for filtration and no
means of or indeed evidence for
intentional Locomotion either along the
sand or through the water
so although these Museum dioramas and
interpretations are certainly compelling
they fall far short of an accurate
picture
both the lifestyles and evolutionary
relationships of the ediacaran organisms
are likely to be much Stranger than we
have yet imagined
[Music]
after the false starts of their
Discovery and recognition
the age complexity and utter strangeness
of the ediacran biota is no longer a
subject of debate
rather it represents one of the greatest
Frontiers in paleontology in the 21st
century
scientists all around the world are
devising ever newer ways to glean as
much information as possible about these
enigmatic organisms that thrived long
before the Cambrian era when animal life
was traditionally thought to have its
roots
field geologists continue to scour the
globe for more species
as well as additional examples of known
species to further our knowledge about
their biodiversity and environmental
distributions
the fossil Rich seafloor surfaces of
mistaken point in Newfoundland are being
laser scanned to the highest possible
resolution
in the hopes of revealing new detail not
immediately obvious to the naked eye
the digital record will also preserve
the paleontological treasure long after
the craggy rocks have been lost to the
Sea
and three-dimensional ediacaran fossils
from Namibia are subjected to CT scans
much like those used in medical imaging
to reveal their hidden structure and any
internal details that may remain within
their Sandstone tombs
scarcely ever as a single group of
fossils been subject to so much intense
examination
and yet even now as they clutch their
secrets close to their quilted ridged
and wrinkled chests
still don't yield any of the animal
features we'd expect for The Missing
Link before the Cambrian explosion
but there's little consensus on an
alternative either
[Music]
a big question that still surrounds
these organisms and one which can help
to narrow down their place on The
evolutionary tree is just how they get
energy and nutrition in sufficient
quantity to allow them to grow larger
than any other life form before them
foreign
Ford discoverer of the first example of
China in England thought that it
represented some kind of seaweed and so
was able to make its own food by
photosynthesis
certainly it's a leaf-like shape is
evocative and there are modern and
fossil examples of seaweeds which pump
their tissues full of air in order to
stay afloat and free of any sediment
that might cover them and their
photosynthetic pigments
[Music]
but examination of the environmental
mistaken Point were examples of chania
are also found in abundance reveals it
to be closer to the deep sea than the
Sun that shallows
in those deep dark Muddy Waters there
would be no light to fuel a
photosynthetic seaweed so anything
living here must find its nutrition
elsewhere
what could be the source of that
nutrition
there are really only two places it can
come from the water or the sediment
itself
some animals today are able to filter
tiny organic particles straight from the
water column including the bizarre
looking two worms found around A black
smoker chimneys a deep sea hydrothermal
vents
but this strategy only really works when
there is plenty of food to be found in
the water
there is a reason the tube worms are
found where they are
and that's because the underwater vents
expel energy-rich particles from deeper
within the Earth's crust
fuels an entire ecosystem to support
these large complex animals
but in the typical ediacron ocean this
nutritional Bounty is sadly lacking
there's no sign of volcanic vents near
any of the fossil sites and without a
much more churned up ocean bottom the
kind of disruption that comes from
burrowing worms for instance which
haven't yet evolved then there's no
mechanism for getting particles into the
water
and so filtering water probably wasn't
how these organisms fed
in fact mostly the acurans didn't
actually live the way that charnia seems
to have many like the spindle-shaped
fractal fuses and the tablecloth-sized
dickinsonia spent their lives pressed
down into the mud
so presumably there was good reason for
doing so
[Music]
and that reason may well have been for
food
[Music]
remember however that none of the
fossils have features we can
definitively recognize as a mouth or a
gut
and so if there's any nutrition to be
had in the mud then it was obtained by
more subtle means
the absorption through the outer tissues
and diffusion to the cells Within
and while this is certainly possible
it's not a very animal-like thing to do
[Music]
dead it's much more common among the
fungi
[Music]
who extend their thread-like High fee
through Modern soils in search of
energy-rich bounty in the form of other
decaying organisms
today fossil evidence suggests that the
fungal Kingdom which is itself closely
related to the animals had already made
its appearance before the ediacaran
period
so this interpretation for some or all
of the fossils is not altogether
unreasonable
and yet among all the diverse forms that
we know that funky can take there has
never been anything like the ediacron
anatomy
while it doesn't rule out a fungal
Affinity it certainly doesn't give us
much to go on
[Music]
so the question remains unsolved for now
scientists have tested almost every
conceivable hypothesis and found nothing
that sticks
[Music]
some have even suggested that these
giant forms aren't truly multicellular
at all but maybe gigantic single-celled
organisms like the nomulite fossils that
make up the Limestone from which the
Great Sphinx is carved
or they could be loose in temporary
colonies of smaller cells which come
together for reproduction or at times of
hardship
but without more supporting evidence
like microscopic fossils or chemical
signatures it's impossible to know this
for sure and unfortunately while the
preservation of the shape of the Acron
fossils is spectacular the sandstones
that typically hold them are very poor
preservers of any other Clues
foreign
of course the possibility remains that
the ediacarans represents something
entirely different to any other life
form we've seen before or since they
could be a false start
failed experiment at multicellularity
before the much more successful animal
organizations came about
[Music]
if that is the case then we would have
absolutely no comparisons no reference
and no anchor to any other part of the
evolutionary tree
foreign
it is as if they are an entire limb that
has fallen from the Tree of Life
a dead-end cul-de-sac leaving no Trace
where it once grew
[Music]
and some scientists are content to leave
it there to consider the ye the Akron
biota in isolation
and not concern themselves with
questions of affinity that seem to be
unanswerable
[Music]
yet considering the examples laid out by
the rest of the three billion year old
paleontological record
and everything we know or believe to be
true about the workings of evolution it
seems entirely implausible that the
ediacaran period contains no ancestors
of animals at all
[Music]
Martin klesner's original reasoning for
pigeonholing the ediacaran forms among
living animal groups was sound even if
his pattern matching overreached itself
foreign
foreign
[Music]
explosion is the most dramatic radiation
of life ever seen on Earth
at its almost inconceivable that the
evolutionary precursors to that
extraordinary moment remain hidden
especially when there are macroscopic
organisms in the period just before
[Music]
how then do we account for the
unfamiliarity of the ediacaran biota
why does nothing look like an animal if
that's what they'll ultimately become
to answer that we need to remind
ourselves that the course of evolution
never did run smooth
it is not a ladder leading from one
straightforward rung to another
and the Tree of Life Is So named purely
because it is so tree-like
there are many branches
most of which may have no future
but it only takes one Rogue Breakaway
lineage to succeed and an entirely New
Path is formed
so any one of the diverse ediacaran
forms could have been the ancestor to
the entire Animal Kingdom
with the others disappearing Into
Obscurity
it's a tale that many of us are familiar
with from a much more recent geological
time
what were the dinosaurs after all but a
failed experiment into giant lizard hood
that ultimately gave rise to birds
perhaps also we are unreasonable in our
expectations that animal ancestors
should look recognizable at all
even the most primitive groups the
cnidarians and sponges which are thought
to have Evolved first among all the
animals look the way they do today
thanks to more than 500 million years of
evolution alongside the rest of the
animal kingdom
[Music]
indeed what is the use of the stinging
cells that Define the jellyfish and
corals if there's nothing else around in
the ocean to sting
foreign
it's more than likely that the first
cnidarians didn't have this diagnostic
characteristic because there was simply
no need for it before any other animals
had evolved
similarly the poorest skeleton of modern
sponges constructed to help the formless
organism filter food particles from the
water column it's only really
sustainable if there are other animals
around to help maintain that structure
without shrimp to clear detritus from a
sponge's Paws they quickly become
blocked and the sponge will die
so without this modern day spa early
sponge creatures would be all but
unrecognizable
[Music]
so there's really no reason to think
that the very first members of these or
indeed any animal group
should look anything like they do today
and if that is the case then we have
come full circle
from discounting the animal affinities
for idiacarans to the conclusion that
they must be the missing links we're
looking for even if we don't know
exactly what we're looking at
some or all of the ediacarans May indeed
be the first tentative steps into animal
Hood
as multicellular forms began to
experiment with tissues organs and novel
body organizations
but have yet to settle on a truly
winning combination
[Music]
this is scientists best guess for now
but the science of the ediacroin biota
is still a little more than 50 years old
it is in its infancy compared to the
long history of much of the rest of
paleontology
there's still much to be done and much
to be discovered
who knows what Insight the next 50 years
will bring
you've been watching the entire history
of the Earth
don't forget to like And subscribe and
leave us a comment to tell us what you
think as we move ever closer to the
Cambrian explosion
arguably the single most important event
in the entire history of life on Earth
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]